feels so good doesn't it looks so good
and yes welcome home back at pnc park
and fans here john it's great to have
him back
and for the pirates left-hander tyler
anderson making his second start pitched
against these cubs last week
pennsylvania lottery numbers went five
innings gave up five hits a couple of
walks seven k's 91 pitches goes through
his delivery but um there's a lot of
deception to his pitches as they come
through the hitting zone and there we go
sped him up with the fastball got him
out in front with the change up
perfectly placed change up he threw that
about a quarter of the time in his last
start perfect location contreras way out
in front he normally generates a lot of
soft contact not very much swing and
miss i guess that just speaks to the
cubs struggles here early on aside from
opening day and they haven't been
hitting here is chris bryant now bryant
has always hit well here at pnc park or
the 1-2 to bryant that one drilled out
towards center field going back is
fowler and it's gone
home run for bryant getaway center field
and just like that the cubs on the board
it is one nothing well they're the uh
the swinging get after approach pays off
as chris brian goes deep for the second
time this year he's kind of been
uh
kind of the highlight in the cubs lineup
so far the quality of his at bats has
been
really good but he's looked good he's
taking a lot of good swings javier baez
2-2 by his weights
and reaches out rips a base hit into
left field
stayed back enough got a piece of it and
hooked it into left yeah you're exactly
right stayed back well enough kept it
kept the bad path in the zone he got on
his front foot
keeps that bat in the in the zone long
enough to get the barrel to that off
speed pitch from anderson
pirates have tied it up off arietta the
sacrifice fly by dustin fowler
ground ball into right
and the cheetah will be tested no he
will not hayward will just throw to
second and adam frazier on base all
three times his base hits scores
stallings from second and gives the
pirates the lead
here's anthony rizzo two to one pirates
now the pitch to rizzo line drive toward
right uh left center that's gonna fall
in there for a base hit anthony gets a
one-out single tying runners-on and the
batter now is javier bios
field one
hit the air down the left side towards
the corner this is a chance it's gone
home run for javi baez he reached down
and scooped it out of the park
and baez with the two-run blast and how
about that and the cubs now lead it
three to two yeah how sweet is that javi
single first time up and now delivers
the long ball it is number two on the
young season for
javi myers
and arietta back to work bottom third of
the order
and first pitch swinging is stallings
lifted in the air
and marissa jake mariznick been busy
today cubs lead 3-2 the pitch by arietta
lifted into left-center playable for
peterson battling the sun back pedaling
squeezing with a blue glove
two down and the pitcher spot due up for
the buckos eric gonzalez the big strong
bearded right-hander arietta fires
breaking ball swinging a mess in the
dirt picked up by contreras he'll throw
to rizzo and that's that one two three a
strikeout for arietta one two three
inning we go to the seventh
the lanky southpaw going to work on
anthony rizzo cubs lead 3-2 eighth
inning rizzo lines one to deep right
field it's got a chance
gone
a screaming line drive home run for
anthony rizzo to right and the cubs now
lead four to two
boy rizz gets that fastball down and in
and he didn't miss it
he stays above this ball with his hands
and just drops the head of the bat
down on this fastball in and it's a
rocket right over that 21 foot wall and
wrote straight right field so big swing
for rizz
and he gets his first home run of the
year
4-2 cubs big moment here for
david bednar and his family and friends
and a line drive to left and a diving
catch by reynolds
he'll get a high five from bednar
one pitch
one out that's how you do it easy breezy
that's a heck of a play out there
bottom eight cubs lead at 4-2 in his
three innings of work craig kimbrell has
been making it look easy
here comes
swang and a miss struck him out that was
a nasty breaking ball
yeah
the only pitch he really swung out in
the sequence was the one way out of the
zone but that's what the ability to
throw that first pitch curve ball for a
strike
set everything up
kimbrell works from the stretch faces
loaded two down the one-two
swinging to miss struck him out and he
comes in and puts out the fire
so now one and two on brian reynolds as
the cubs try to take the opener
and a swing and a missed ball game cubs
win
kimbrell comes in and for the first time
in his career in the regular season
picks up a five out save again your
final score the cubs win it four to two